what's the difference between being
funny and writing something that's funny
what's the difference between being
funny and writing something that's funny
uh well being funny is uh you're sitting
around a table and you you make a
comment and in in the context of what's
happening around the table uh a bunch of
people laugh but writing funny is about
creating a truth for a character
who is saying something
inexpertly in a way that the character
is not realizing he or she is being
funny but the result is is a is a comic
moment that the audience can appreciate
um and and again it comes from
sharing your own life
and then being truthful in in imaginary
circumstances but being truthful in a
way
that lets us see the flaws
when you know being truthful in
imaginary circumstances is something
that that actors have heard from you
know Stan slavsky and Meisner
traumatic actors but if you think about
what drama does
uh it's like it's like you know when
people have past lives they're never
janitors
they're always Queens for sure or
Emperors or they were viziers they're
never the garbage collector they're
they're they're never a guy who worked
who worked as you know as a as a chef in
a diner in a past life and so when when
when a dramatic actor is being truthful
in imaginary circumstances their
being great
they're being serious they're they're
accruing all types of positive virtues
to themselves the comic actor tells the
truth the comic actor allows themselves
to be
less than stupid because you know the
point is is that we are
we are if we you know if we just tell
the truth about ourselves we're not
perfect we make mistakes we screw up all
the time there's a
there's a wonderful moment in uh Judd
apatos this is 40. where there's a
they're having a party and they're these
cupcakes and the wife just throws the
cupcakes away because yeah we don't need
all these cupcakes and then the next
scene you see Judd Apatow
eating the cupcake from the garbage and
I laughed
how can you be funny how can you write
funny I laugh because yeah I've done
that
don't tell my wife uh but not a
disgusting garbage with a lot of
disgusting things but you know just kind
of on top so it was still it was still
the three second rule but but that's
that's how he creates comedy he just
takes
from his life from the from the lives of
uh of of people that he knows people
around him and he tries to tell the
truth based on character
based on character so you're not
um you're not trying to come up with the
funniest thing you can think of uh
you're trying to come up with what would
this character say In This Moment
there's uh
there's a great uh this is this is old
this is if you if you remember radio
um there's this great scene from Jack
Benny radio Series in which
um Robert comes up to him and the robber
says your money or your life
and the the comedy writers who were
writing this the episode were stuck what
could we say what's his answer so
they're thinking about it and one of
them's on the couch and the other one's
pacing and says you have anything he
says I'm thinking
and they went
said
and they gave that's the line that Jack
Penny says so somebody says your money
or your life and there's this big pause
and Jack Benny and his inimitable way
goes I'm thinking and this is the
longest recorded laughter in the history
of radio comedy
uh because that's what somebody would
say when they're stuck and they don't
know what to say there's
um
there's an episode of Everybody Loves
Raymond
um in which Robert the big hulking
Brother played by Brad Garrett brings
home what he thinks is the one uh and
that's the title of the episode she's
the one and so everybody's talking and
and you know not paying attention and uh
Raymond's gonna bring some desserts out
to the table and he sees the girl who's
the one
catch a fly
trap the fly look around make sure
nobody's looking she doesn't realize
Raymond's seeing her
she picks it up
she pops the fly in the mouth
and Raymond
is frozen and he stays Frozen a ray
Romana stays Frozen for about four and a
half minutes and there's all action
around him and his parents come in
there's all this stuff and finally
Robert says so what do you think
and he just turned to her and says she's
not the one which is how could you write
a better line than that but because
you're not trying to be funny
you're trying to think
what would this character say In This
Moment uh given that the character is
not the greatest Raider in the world and
and given who he is and knowing who he
is so so the way to write funny is to
tell your own truth to tell the truth
about yourself and to tell the truth
about uh the characters who you know and
tell the truth about
what you know and who you know and as
truthfully as possible one one more
example from the early age of Television
I'm sorry I'm old okay I'll I'll talk
about Tick Tock in a second
um
Norman Lear adapted this British series
uh uh till death does dupart and he's
adapting it for an American audience and
so he's got this character Archie Bunker
now who's Archie Bunker in the in the
British series he's this old codger
who's kind of bigoted
so how did Norman Lear write him funny
he just thought of his father
his father used to say uh you know
stifled thing bad he had Archie say that
his father once said to him you're the
laziest white man and you know whatever
he had Archie say that how did Ray how
did Phil Rosenthal who's the showrunner
on um Everybody Loves Raymond how did he
write the mother Marie well that's his
mother
so he doesn't have to invent anything
he just has to recollect it the first
book really tried to talk about what are
the discrete tools that aren't taught in
universities or conservatories that can
help you take a scene that isn't working
and make it work
um and and we have a number of tools
like uh uh positive action and in
metaphorical relationship
um and straight line wavy line uh those
tools in the first book are designed to
help a writer or director say okay this
scene is kind of flat the scene isn't
working
um and what are the techniques that we
can use to to make it better or what are
the techniques that we can use to
analyze why it's not working
so the whole the whole first book was
really designed to talk about what
comedy is how it works why it works
what's happening when it's not working
and how can you fix it and then I was so
I was doing these workshops this is this
is before the pandemic uh do you
remember before the pandemic uh you know
there was this pandemic and everybody
had to stay home and not go anywhere uh
so before the pandemic I would go out I
would go around the world uh no one was
more surprised than me that always been
being invited around the world I would
go around the world and I would do these
workshops and inevitably somebody would
say okay but in this script how about
this
and I would try to give them an answer
and I was doing script consultations but
it made me think
well how does how does what I'm talking
about how does that translate to a whole
narrative and so that's where the second
book came out of
um the comic heroes Journey uh my friend
Chris bobler had written the The
Writer's Journey which is based on the
works of Joseph Joseph Campbell
and so I ripped him off and I I told him
I'm ripping off your title no one can
come up with a better title than that
but you thanked him in the forward right
I did that forward uh so that's how we
do it in Hollywood uh yeah I mean uh I
didn't give him any money but I did
thank him in the forward uh so the comic
heroes Journey uh was really taking a
look at
so what's different in a comedy in a
comic narrative uh that is that
follows the hero's journey it's at
points but then importantly deviates it
and how does it do how does it deviate
it and where does it deviate it and what
are those changes and what are those
important points that that might not be
covered in in an otherwise you know
Wonderful book
um by John truby or Robert McKee or or
Chris Vogler when they're specifically
talking about comedy